coming up cosmic queries the black hole
edition Chuck is going into our black
hole bag to get quick we've got your
question yeah on that very topic so
youtuber verse check it out coming up
now this is Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
I'm with Chuck nice coho that's right
Chuck and we are recording live from my
office at the Hayden Planetarium of the
American Museum of Natural History right
here in New York City better known as
the cosmic crib Oh crib welcome to the
company that's right those hi currency
when I was in college
yeah I'd heard anybody use it anymore no
yeah no it's kind of uh yeah you're just
very dates very dated yeah yeah but
still sounds cool to quit does yeah
what's up man just chilling in my crib
see it work work work for anybody over
50 so this is actually part two of
cosmic queries we began last time that's
right because we had sufficient
questions to populate to cosmic queries
on black holes and dark energy people
love it know about the dark energy and
black hole and since we don't know
anything about dark energy I want to
know about it too that's right all right
give it to me what do you have all right
so we are going to start with a patreon
veteran as is our habit absolutely so
this is Chris Hampton and he says hey
Hawking radiation states that a black
hole will eventually evaporate
completely because it's releasing small
amounts of energy slash mass overtime
but wouldn't the black holes consumption
of matter overpower the radiation making
the black hole grow instead of yeah good
so if you have an isolated black hole
it's not consuming matter right there's
nobody there to eat exactly you have to
come embarrassingly too close to it for
it to tidally just stress you and
capture you and now okay let's get right
and you have to be moving not too fast
otherwise you'll just whiz by right
the black holes are not some voracious
vacuum cleaner that sucks up everything
it sees right that's a little blacker
and a big blob that's right there's
supermassive black holes like it is
funny this voice frequency thing like
you never have a high frequency voice
selling a truck right that's trill which
now I want to see Mike Tyson actually
sell dodge Rams just like you know
that's right it's it's RAM talk Dodge
Ram okay cuz he is a tough guy he's a
tough question whether that will
compensate exactly for the voice exactly
what's it you know the voice voice of
God is never high high pitch no it's
never just like hey guys Michael Jackson
was allowed to be the voice of God okay
so this information that okay it
consumes okay if it's by itself life
stuff that yes clearly and as correctly
surmised if it has a food source right
it's just going to eat and the Bakke
radiation will go will be insignificant
right of a loss relative to what it's
eating that's it but eventually all
black holes will have eaten anything
they can eat right in their refrigerator
at that point then it'll slowly start
evaporating at a higher rate than it was
gaining mass that's who that's that's
how that plays out and the evaporation
though yeah nothing can escape what is
actually evaporating good question
evaporation is we're using the term
loosely okay all right so what's
actually happening and it's it's
brilliant it's just it's it is beautiful
okay it's so what's going on is a black
hole
the gravitational field in the vicinity
of a black hole okay it's so intense
right that it will spontaneously create
matter holy crap so the energy density
because it equals MC squared uh-huh if I
have matter I can turn it into energy
that's what bought the nuclear bombs do
but if I have energy I can turn it into
matter right the energy density in the
field of black holes is so intense right
outside the event horizon outside the
event horizon it will create particles
Wow out of the gravitational energy
density of the field now watch here's
them here's this here's spooky part okay
okay
these particles were not inside the
event horizon they're created outside
the event horizon right okay now watch
what happens when anytime you make
particles from energy you make two
particles every time okay matter and
antimatter pair Wow don't if you knew
that oh yeah okay and they will travel
in the exact opposite directions from
each other that's it that means one
escapes the other goes right back on in
right okay so but the one that escapes
escapes forever right if you measure the
mass of the black hole it is now less by
the mass of that one particle that
escaped even though these particles were
created in the gravity field of the
black hole itself nice so it's giving of
itself just from the energy density of
the gravitational field it's it's it's
really a remarkable fact that is
remarkable right Wow yes and so Hawking
figured this out okay and then concluded
if this keeps up the whole black holes
going right at some point right right
right
amazing mm-hmm so it's and in fact the
smaller the black hole the faster it
will radiate that's it okay it's a
surface-area thing alert because we have
a whole show on yeah
it's so the larger the object if it
let's say it's a sphere the larger the
object the less surface area it has
relative to the volume right okay and
the smaller you are the more is your
surface area relative to your font this
is why children and babies should not
spend too long in the hot tub right
because their connection to the hot
environment is way more devastating to
their body than it is of your bigger
right that's all
so as the black hole gets smaller and
smaller the rate of evaporation
increases because its surface area gets
larger and larger compared to the volume
that's inside of it Wow surface area of
the event horizon and the intensity of
the energy goes up and so it's very last
gasp is a pulse of light of the highest
known energy which are gamma rays Wow
okay that's pretty cool so the original
paper written by Hawking talked about
bursts of gamma rays in the universe
from black holes evaporating in their
very last gasp and then we saw gamma
rays in the universe with a telescope
after the data would Declassified we had
a telescope launched in the early 70s
trust but verify right oh let's sign the
test ban treaty no nuclear tests in the
atmosphere anywhere else we said okay
rush Russkies but we're gonna put up a
satellite that'll look for gamma rays
just in case you don't fulfill the the
treaty and we started setting gamma-ray
like every day it's like we got some
ground truth on this checked other
satellites no explosions anywhere a
whole brand-new field of astrophysics
was pried open by accident because we're
trying to preserve a fly because we
don't trust the rust because we don't
trust the Russians Andy I don't know why
we win Chester essence there's such good
people I wanna be friends with good
people all around that's right so those
gamma-ray bursts are they these black
holes no because you can look at the
properties and it's not right okay
fascinating yeah man thank you hey Chris
thank you for that that was really a
nice trip man I love it oh yeah alright
next patreon question governor alright
there we go this is from
okk steals funny fake one okay you're
just screwing with me I know that now
all right I don't think I have a proper
question here you have a proper name
either
can you please making people feel good
can you tell me about the singularity of
a black hole like whatever you know
about it thanks in advance
yeah yeah yeah I'll tell you what we a
center of a black hole supposedly a
singularity I'll tell you what we know
go ahead all right I the collapse of a
thing to a black hole we take it to a
black hole because there's no known
force in the to us in the universe that
would prevent it and if you do the math
the gravity is so severe that it will
collapse to get denser and denser and
denser until it is infinitely small
which would make it infinitely dense
correct because density is mass divided
by a volume but grams per cubic
centimeter right okay pounds per cubic
foot these are statements of density so
if you have a certain amount of mass and
the volume goes to 0 what happens if you
divide by zero well you get an error
yeah my calculator okay before you get
to zero the numbers get astronomically
large right so actually get to infinity
so it is infinitely dense and so can you
even have that in nature is the question
Wow I don't know right
but invoking only Einstein's general
theory of relativity you get a point of
infinite density right strengths
theorists came along and said we got
this it's not infinite density there's
strings and there's another thing going
on in the universe that's why you bring
in string theorists okay we ring the
bell they come in and say we got this
you needed extra physics on top of
general relativity to understand the
singularity and what you did that they
say hey this is good to us let's
the singularity that began the universe
itself hmm the Big Bang singularity
right so this gives you access to
previously mysterious elements taking
Einstein's theories to their limits so
if there's no singularity that could be
something else but according to Einstein
that's what you get
gods yeah yeah but we're admitting that
Einstein's theory is incomplete at the
singularity we're waiting for a bigger
theory to come along to replace it right
okay that's pretty fascinating yeah yeah
I just love it because yeah that makes
sense it's like there's a single point
and how did you even wrap your head
right right right yeah it's that's right
why we're awaiting some new physics war
we got a successfully wrap her head
around something infinitely small but
infinitely dense see so what see I get
the infinitely small infinitely dense I
mean you know I see there's at the
center that's at the center the black
hole and so if you if you were if the
black hole's rotating right then it's
not a single ER it's a doughnut uh a
regular Rick rule nice I like that word
I learned it from my son I gotta be
honest he said regularity yes he came up
with that word I don't think he came up
with it but that's what he told me it
wasn't him that it's not all regular I
said it's a singularity and then he went
to Janna Levin and she said yes it's a
regularity see you boy I just wanted
wants to start an astrophysics Club yeah
his middle school school yes but not a
comedy club not a comma thank you Jesus
I don't care I'm just happy that he does
not want to go down this path
yes be an astrophysicist and write some
books and take care of your father
yeah okay but anyway yeah yeah that's
pretty cool
it's those messy I have a better idea
for what the my scripts okay you're
taking all these papers that you hold
hold on I'll hold the papers hey I have
a black bag here these are on my quest
actually this is an actual black hole
okay okay because first it says it it
says a bad
I do all that stuff in my office all
that's hilarity and as all that bad okay
and as all black holes do the watch you
as you fall in that's hilarious
okay so there's my black hole bed it's a
black hole bag got a drawstring okay so
put them in here okay I'm putting all
the beds now I'll just pull them out oh
well now let's just listen you get your
you get your question answered at random
I didn't experiment with what was inside
of here oh yeah you just did that
experiment actly I here we go alright
alright here we go
Chris Wakefield wants to know this hi
it's Chris it's a philosophy question
since every galaxy we observed so far
has had a supermassive black hole at the
center of it and theoretically a black
hole could be turned into a wormhole
what if they were used as save points
like in a video game across space and
time for a creator of sorts to get
across galaxies more quickly to create
what we know as space just a weird
thought ahead all right so Chris number
one please give me the number of your
weed dealer
the first thing but I think what he
wants is because black holes and
wormholes are related and some may be
related okay and he wants to know
whether there's some I might be
exaggerating his question okay there's
some intergalactic highway system yes
that connects one galaxy to another yeah
that Ross the universe right through
these black hole these black holes in
other words like it's you know kind of
like what's that what's that City
Milwaukee with where they have number
walking you're talking about in a soda
it's it's shows the name of the state
I'm saying but it's in Minnesota
Minneapolis
so many have them they have you walk you
walk it you never you have to go outside
mean when it's 40 for one really cold
when you're the forties a lot between
buildings right right and there's Skyway
news
it's called Skyway I think so skyrocket
is called yeah yeah way and to me what
the first time I saw it it looked like
an ant farm oh that's funny the human
habit rail yeah I didn't know I felt
uncomfortable in that I said this is
some where we are in someone's zoo right
so those things are connected so you
never have to go out exactly so here's
the thing mmm-hmm the I lived
nobody would live the idea more than I
would here's the thing if a black hole
which only eats things is a portal to a
wormhole the other side of that wormhole
can't also be a black hole right it had
because then you would be shoving things
out that's called the white hole all
right yes now see what white hole gotta
be given in a black hole gotta be taken
yeah that's what I'm trying to figure
look not every reference is bad okay the
two black thing all right
okay okay all right
the black plague kiss my black you just
said you were born too late to join the
black pan so is it really a white hole
that's why I'm here so that's a double
reference back the blessing there's the
group from the racism right and the
movie that's right right and the guy
that uses vibranium so yeah yeah so
we're worried we're talking about the
fact that there is something called a
white hole yes
so something called white hand that you
didn't just which would be mad I did not
totally make it up and this was explored
in the 1970s okay when the mathematics
of black holes were coming to maturity
and someone posit posited well if you
have a black hole hey what's on the
other side it would be like a white hole
I mean I mean why not
where everything only comes out right
then how would you connect them with a
wormhole so this you get this you get
three for one right deal on that and
then you can ask yourself what a white
hole would look like in the universe so
in the 1970s we said that this is what a
white hole would look like let's check
the data that's good let's go to the
universe right nothing in the universe
resembled it not even quasars which are
intense emanations of light from the
distant universe in a very small volume
so we so we abandoned that ok so if you
get I don't mind wormholes connecting
the galaxies I just don't see how you
would invoke the black hole to do to do
it that's it all right but there's a
great question go take a break
yep before we get lost in the black hole
back and when we come back more cosmic
queries black holes and dark energy when
we return
we're back Startalk cosmic queries black
holes dark energy yes we have so many
questions it's part two this is part two
in for this part alright my special
black hole bang right whole bag that's
hilarious
it's just black hole that's right
alright and I don't know why they Google
eyes on it but okay so really I'm
reaching in the black hole and whatever
funny if my hand just came out that
would be really freaky it'd be a
wormhole the wormhole black hole bag
alright alright hey this is my crush
from Facebook and he says if nothing can
escape a black hole including light and
nothing can move trap move or travel
faster than light how is their massive
Jets of x-rays coming off many super
massive black holes wouldn't that mean
that these particles slash waves have
been accelerated beyond the speed of
light people paying attention to me
these people read their stuff on the
game why are you ripping up the band the
boys question I was trying to make it
for it I'm like you know just emphasis
and emphasis yeah I was trying to you
know be emphatic but instead I took a
question you intercept really well or
belt
have you ever done that with a golf
course yes like this I'm probably take a
belt nice nap that's all it's my
favorite in life I just take the belt do
you ever go I have about give me give me
I just want to show you something ok
yeah ok ok so watch yeah alright so this
I just want to show you those are you
listening Neil now has my belt my pocket
are down around my ankles okay Neil has
my belt this is just I just wanna show
you okay Wow you see that yes okay so it
turns out right that sound
what is only made mm-hmm at the last
instant that these make contact okay
that make sense okay right but if you
put your finger there no I'm not I
promise which drive how to church up
this we go way back alright okay I trust
you here we go just again okay
put your finger in I'll come on there go
ahead oh look oh my gosh see that look
at that you didn't know but I had no
idea so you can scare people with it
right but really it is and nothing it
doesn't that's amazing because you're
only this listen I'm black that Belton
that represents all right oh my god I've
never seen that I can't wait to go home
and do this to my five-year-old now put
your finger in there that was awesome
okay
alright you can put your while I'm
answering yeah so what so the question
was Oh about that okay so should easy
super math these x-rays that there's a
handoff of these supermassive black hole
here's what happened you have all this
matter trying to get into the black hole
gosh not on purpose not trying to not
get in the black hole right all right
most matter that falls towards a black
hole is not falling exactly on line with
this location in space that's it that
would be unusual right typically it
would just fall off to the side one
direction or another okay so it turns
out the system the rotating system as
matter tries to come in it'll miss the
black hole but then it'll get pulled
into orbit around it that's it okay and
so now you have this circulating matter
right and we have a term for it's called
an accretion disk an accretion it's
accreting material all right as this
accretion disk feeds the black hole the
innermost part of it goes unstable in
its orbit and then it spirals down and
that's lost forever right okay but in
order for all this matter that used to
be out here right to end up here mm-hmm
there's a lot of gravitational energy it
has to release to do that so let me let
me just a little more TMI on this
already all right go for it if I just
drop something towards Earth
what happens to its speed it inside
celery accelerates right right okay all
right nine point eight centimeters per
second squared or so meters per second
meter square so it's neither meters per
sec all right so so here's the thing so
to get from some distant place to the
black hole right and then stop moving
right where does all that energy go all
right and what I'm saying is any matter
that's trying to get to the black hole
from far away is gonna have to release
that energy if it's gonna land where the
black hole is right and so since most of
it misses the black hole goes to the
side you get this disc and so you have
this disc of material all trying to get
in and there's friction between the
inner layers that rotate faster than the
outer layers there's material hating it
and then again it's stopping because it
hit it but that's a collision with it
and we have bright spots that show up on
these accretion discs right that's an
active place yeah that's and if you're a
disc and you're trying to radiate you
can't radiate through the disc because
there's Dick's stuff there right where's
the only place that's free and clear to
spit up material of an energy above on
below those okay all right so that's
great so you have this thick accretion
disk and it's basically empty on the top
and bottom right so all the energy that
is trying to get in and can't will get
released in the opposite directions and
you get generally generally get two
discs right now on the poles of this
accretion disk that's to get to Jets
that's yeah coming out at the poles of
the accretion that's that's amazing yeah
it is completely lays on all the
pictures that you see of the black hole
with that's with the Jets with the enemy
and this is material that never got into
the event horizon right so it's not good
it's escaping the black hole it never
made it he never made it there in the
first but actually the dejected nah
party going club people that were not
allowed and rejected from the the velvet
rope they wouldn't just walk away they
got you exactly that is why yeah so
there it is and that's why so so well
you only get it if you have an accretion
disk right and if creasing disk is
really thin and sparse right then the
energy can go kinda in multiple
directions you won't get these really
strong strong plumes notified and what
it also has a way of doing is it's the
term is colonnades so it actually makes
everything come out only in that one
direction like in a pencil beam nice
alright so if you don't happen to be in
a sight line to it right it's not gonna
be very bright to you exactly so there's
some galaxies that are supremely bright
mm-hmm and it's because we think that
this jet is actually facing directly
towards you with all this energy focused
down into this jet that is amazing stuff
what a great question do you go nice mix
it up going in going in the black hole
alright and I'm pulling out mm-hmm there
we go this is a canola Bradford canola
once oh no I'm sorry
Gionta Gionta Bradford how can Cano to
become Chianti ma'am because I just made
it bad alright alright Chianti wants to
know this if photons have no mass how
does the gravitational force of the
black hole pull in the photons oh what a
great cool oh oh I can answer that in
two ways okay
each of them kind of mind-blowing all
right good are you ready oddly yes
please okay excellent so the first one
is simple right energy and mass are the
same there you go two sides of the same
coin right you can plug the energy the
photon into the equals mc-squared
equation mhm that's the e right and
divide that by C squared and out the
other side comes the mass right and the
cool thing is and that makes sense
that's why you have an equals
that's that's not equal signs wrong what
are you doing to calculate equals MC
squared is the same as M equals e
divided by C exactly so C is the speed
of light squared so you take your energy
the photon divided by c YC with it you
get a mass out of that there you go so
now you can think of the black hole
attracting a mass right and it'll
attract it in exactly the way it'll
track the photon exactly where would a
mass of that amount okay all right okay
but but wait that's not the more
interesting answer okay well you had me
okay Photon
okay travels along the fabric of
space-time at all times all right give
me a second man wait a second please
give me one second a photon travels
along the fabric of space-time yes at
all time yes so therefore yes it is not
traveling at any time although it's
traveling in time and space you want to
look too far okay okay smart full and
explosion here we go my brain is so here
we go go go for it so here we go
they even holding aside the fact that
because the photon goes at the speed of
light it has no time this whole lattice
up because time has slowed down so much
is actually stopped for a photon so
photon has no time at all it has no
inner clock so the instant it is emitted
anywhere in the universe okay
is the same instant as it is absorbed by
your detector at the business end of
your telescope so the flip to it to it
it knows nothing of the journey between
being formed and being on hitting
something I mean getting absorbed okay
okay by the way I say about my full time
oh if you're on the beach sunning
yourself there's a photon from across
the galaxy right travel hole gun and
lands on your on your buttocks right
you've heard of the famous experiment
conducted by Sir Arthur Eddington oh of
course
my favorite yes sir authors
our Tea Party so four years after
Einstein put forth his prediction right
that gravity bends Spain mm-hmm Arthur
Eddington during a total solar eclipse
conducting in a tradition I know that's
why I knew you knew it to measure
whether like coming by the edge of the
Sun right whether its path was bent and
the way you do that is you get a map of
all the stars during a solar eclipse
because you can't see the stars all
right and get their exact position on
the sky yes their way six months later
and take a picture of that same part of
the sky six much the Sun is not in right
there it is and then you compare their
positions right and he found that the
star is closer to where the Sun was
their position had shifted Wow and so
this is the bending of starlight around
the Sun so cool okay so here's the point
go ahead the starlight never bent the
light the photons always took a straight
line that straight line was bent in the
fabric of space exactly which means the
footer knew nothing else but to take
that path Wow
so the actual curvature of space-time
itself is surfing yes that's what the
photon is surfing yeah the action yes
curvature of space-time itself yes
please and is water my god holy bleep
oops okay so oh my god that's amazing so
in that context the black hole isn't
sucking in the photon no the phone is
just too far on the curve on a
skateboard in a pool and it's just
following the dip of the pool yeah there
there you have it
yes photons do that
ah that's so awesome yes so light
technically never curves because that is
a straight line to it Wow to it wow
that's so in other words let's say the
path came around came around the butt
the path came around right did you stand
here right it looks straight in this
direction you're seeing this spot that's
right that's what's because space curve
that's right that's amazing that is so
cool so first base in the photometer
ditch is going in a straight line oh my
god that's so cool yeah that is really
great there you go that's good stuff
right there baby listen I don't even
want to finish this [ __ ] let's go home
I'm good we gotta take a break coming up
yet another segment of cosmic queries
black hole dark energy edition on
Startalk
we're back Startalk cosmic queries black
holes I guess they're black holes lack
holes black holes and dark energy that's
right I got to add something to my
answer about but you were so Ted I was
it's good stuff you handle more I I'm
not sure I my head might explode it's
great that okay go ahead the experiment
that showed that light bent coming
around the Sun right in 1919 right okay
four years after Einstein had his idea
1915 published in 1960 so you might see
both of those dates but referring to the
same the ideas right so he predicts that
space will curve in the vicinity of
strong gravity or any gravity but you
want to be able to measure it so you
want a strong gravity source like the
Sun so watch it turns out if you plug
the energy of the photon into equals
mc-squared and get a mass and then
predict what the curve would be you get
newton's answer to that question don't
get ice tunnels answer okay in fact
Newton that's ordinary gravity it's a
mass and a thing right okay that that
would be the rubber seat no we're not
yet at the rubber Newton doesn't know
anything about rubber sheets right it's
just I'm a mass you're a mask we attract
each other right okay so even though it
would have never been measured before
the curving of light right it had to
curve by the amount predicted by
Einstein absolutely it can't have just
been curved light so you will see news
accounts remembering this experiment say
and the blight bent around the Sun
proving Einstein no that just proved
that gravity photons response to gravity
exactly okay I get to what you say now
right okay
yes so when you invoke einstein's
full-blown general theory of relativity
equations you predict twice the
deflection gotcha of the beam of light
than a standard calculation with Isaac
Newton and the measurements made by Sir
Arthur and Artie hyperbole Artie and his
measurements recovered that full factor
of two
we hope you would have measured so the
problem is no one had measured the
curvature of like before right so it
gets bundled together with what would
have happened if the light curve but was
not as big as Einstein's number exactly
would have just been Newton your light
is also curving right exactly because
because Newton did know anything about
equals mc-squared exactly so yeah so now
it's just like big object okay look mass
right attracts and so now that's why you
got the curve made you get the you just
got you would occur because the gravity
pulls exactly where as Einstein in the
fabric and the face of space-time I run
the math on his equations you get a
factor of 2 greater than Y its burger oh
my god which is right exactly so that's
amazing and that there shows you that
it's the fabric of space-time itself
rather than pulling on something space
tells matter how to move right matter
tells space how to curve ice this is
going there you go that's a quote from
John Archibald wheeler as a student of
Albert Einstein and I met my tobe wife
in his relativity class oh sweet yeah
all right black hole bag to the black
hole pulling out all right hey Fernando
or Rodriguez wants to know this is it
possible that there could be from
Hackensack it's just you know and
Fernando Rodriguez manases Fernando
Rodriguez I like for Nandu is so very
good to meet you pushing boots I was
about to say perhaps you know my friend
[Laughter]
Tony was one of the parties characters I
love it all of Shrek okay go okay is it
possible that dark energy and dark
matter are stuff permeating into our you
know
from another nearby universe and the our
matter and energy is being permeated
into another universe here's the caveat
via black holes so I mean just think
about it
hold off on dark energy for a moment
because that's just everywhere and I it
would not lend itself as well to this
expectation as dark matter would ok ok
so dark matter is a source of gravity
about which we know nothing god see oh
no it's not black holes it's not it's
just gravity out there we don't know
what's causing write out maybe it's some
new particle we've got top people
looking for new particles nice part of
they don't interact with you and any
kind of way didn't care about you so it
could be just another sort of coexisting
state of matter that we have to learn
about alright that's it
what'd I do you did you know this I
don't know if you knew that light is
trapped within our universe you can't
get out
but gravity can that's wild yes isn't
that interesting that is very yes and I
never took a full-up field theory course
in graduate school where I would have
learned this so I'm describing this too
because this is what people who I trust
and where experts have told me okay not
because I did the cow of you know stuff
I talked about you I've done the
calculations a guy's okay but the things
I am I've just trust in them okay
field theory course right in it the
properties of gravity are such that it
is not contained within our universe
okay so if there's a parallel universe
it in principle could feel the effects
of gravity in our universe well then so
would the opposite be true right all
right so if that's the case maybe
there's a hunkering universe out there
because 85% of the gravity of our
universe comes from what we call dark
honor right 85% Wow
all right so we are just blips on a you
know with froth on the wave as waves of
the ocean except so perhaps there's a
hunkering galaxy on hunkering universe
six times the mass of our actually it
has to be more than that because to come
out of the universe
to be even stronger than the ordinary
gravity you'd feel within the universe
okay it's because it's coming out in
another dimension right alright so in
other words if you if you scream to
someone your voice dilutes as it gets as
it spreads out right by AB weight we're
eight we can calculate now suppose
you're also screaming into another
dimension so if you're screaming then
the energy you need to have strength
going to that extra dimension mm-hmm and
still matter to wherever its head it's
got to be much bigger than just went
into your own dimensions here so every
dimension you add it dilutes faster let
me put it that way okay okay okay that's
it like for example if I'm sending
marbles down a one-way path right
there's no dilution right because all
the marbles I just aren't rolling down
rolling down a bit that's enough I
spread it out like this in a fan now the
marbles will dilute into a fan right
okay okay mathematically the dilute as
one over R okay all right now if I over
one over the distance now if I dilute it
into a cone they'll do like one over R
squared gods as those light and as does
gravity guys if I now dilute it into a
higher dimension than that right you
need it will don't like one over the
fourth power
that's funny cuz you just went you did
you went from flat to two to three
demand that's so the higher to add a
dimension you need that dimension to get
to the other universe that's right so
the gravity help you'd like that much
more powerful okay but suppose it was
supposed 12 times the mass of our
universe or a hundred times the mass or
it could be their gravity seeping into
the ordinary mass or ordinary gravity
right seeping into our universe and
since we can't see the origin which is
which is that is so I'm serious that's
right
oh my god that makes so much sense
though well it really makes so much
and here we are trying to touch an
elephant it's not even that exactly
right
that is cool so I'm all for that that's
the solution I want I love is that would
there be evidence indirect though it was
of another parallel universe to us
that's so wild right cuz you know you
know who's looking for the new particle
that it could be particle physicists
right so their hammers looking for nails
yeah you know right that's it so I'm not
any of those hammers I'm looking for
whatever is out there right I'll take
any of it fantastic man
that's good yeah it's really is really
really fun concepts gotta be like the
cutting-edge frontier of all physics and
just for reference not that I think
everyone got that example but let me
give a simpler one just in case you want
it yeah I mean I got it but that's a
good that's that's it was a good example
within a sheet of paper right right and
that's your whole world right but you're
a three-dimensional person looking at we
poor creatures and you have a hollow
sphere and we might have done this on
another show yes we did I drop that
sphere pass that sphere through your
sheet of paper that's it how will you
describe that to your other scientists
in the sheet of paper well first there's
a dot right and then the dot becomes a
circle this circle gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and then it hits a
maximum point started close and they'll
close it and then it answers a service
disappears nice who knows where it went
I don't know right where do you just
past a sphere through us right so there
could be higher dimensional things
influencing your space environment that
you it's just it's the stuff of legend
right Lord right in that sort of thing
that's cool yeah Wow
all right back to the bathroom or all
right here we go
mm-hmm all right this is Jackson Welch
Jackson wells from Instagram wants to
know if a solar system further so people
can st. question to us from all platform
everywhere yeah okay good we're
everywhere Instagram idea and he says a
if a solar system further from the black
hole of our galaxy has a planet which
inhabits inhabits intelligent life would
time be faster on
planet relative to ours also if their
planet had life developed at the same
time as ours might they be more advanced
due to the relative time difference and
thus having had quote unquote more time
to develop so the gravitational field of
the black hole is so weak by the time
you get out here - it's not a thing it's
just not a thing it's not a thing so no
no no lose sleep over that right and so
but what is interesting is and this is
like inside baseball here but it turns
out our speeds should be dropping off as
you get out so here's the whole galaxy
we have flat disc spiral galaxy and you
get farther out this speed should be
dropping off because you're farther away
from the center of the action
but they're not they're like stable
right they're quote flat so our speed is
the same basically as that of stars
orbiting exterior to us something is
enabling that to happen something is
having them go faster than they
otherwise would this was a discovery
made in 1976 by Vera Rubin and that was
the discovery of dark matter in galaxies
themselves Oh
so Dark Matter is actually a fermion
seeing galaxies to the point where our
rotation rotation rate should be slower
and the Dark Matter is giving it more
gravity to turn it Wow yeah so now is
that so that means is that we have the
same speed exactly and so therefore
there's not any relative anything but
even if we did start life at the same
time it could easily have life way
sooner than we did or way later because
every branch in the tree of life is an
enormous contingency of events mm-hmm
suppose the asteroid never took out the
dinosaurs right we would all still be
you know small rodents running underfoot
trying to avoid being orders for I'm
going to say
I'm trying to think of the dinosaur now
t-rex thank you but no I wanted to go
with the clever girl
that one which one is in the Raptor Oh
lots of Raptor clever yeah yeah I
remember that line yeah bad Jurassic
Park right before he gets by the way you
know how big those Raptors actually are
they're about this big
oh really they're small yeah we have
minute um display oh yeah yeah yeah I
could kick it I could talk I could
totally bust his ass so that's so funny
here I say I'm talking to a fox yeah but
they pumped him up for the movie yes
just to make him a little more eye to
eye right you know obviously something
big can kill you but something your size
right that's also form that's a fight
that's the fight fight that you gonna
lose yes so fine yeah you think it's a
fight and then you run and then you get
slashed open with these razor-sharp
talons of a velociraptor and you're like
why did I bring a belly to a raptor
fight I don't know what I'm saying
the point is almost anything and we went
three billion years with single-celled
life right if there's something else
that pump oxygen into the air faster
than they did right we'd have had an
oxygenated atmosphere what earlier
enabling oxygen metabolism life to take
root sooner than it did on another
planet perhaps rather than here if you
want to use earth as some kind of
measure of things so there could be
life-forms on planets just as old as
ours that are a billion times more
evolution they're really advanced than
we are right a billion years
that's fine about that that's great oh
yeah that's pretty well you got it yeah
do it I think that's it no we're out of
time this wait stick your head in it
[Music]
alright well thanks for tuning in nobody
tunes anything anymore this is transfer
thanks for thanks for clicking on click
yeah whatever you did thanks for
listening watching this has been
Startalk cosmic queries edition black
holes and dark energy Chuck nice over
here
always a pleasure brother all right I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist signing off on my office
Hayden Planetarium where I'm telling you
as I always do to keep looking
[Applause]
[Music]